command the seas with history's most
iconic war vessels in the latest
free-to-play combat game world of
warships download now free-to-play games
get a pretty bad rap and sometimes okay
well a lot of times that's for a really
good reason those crappy games aside
though they are free to play games that
are actually totally worth your time
just to prove it to you here are six of
them
I may not be any good at Team Fortress 2
but that doesn't stop me from playing it
or admitting that it's a really great
game to play for free if all you know
about tf2 is that it has a shitload of
hats you're really missing out
Team Fortress 2 is the perfect
plug-and-play team-based shooter to jump
into with a few friends even though it's
getting pretty old now
the maps are fun and well designed the
shooting is enjoyable and the characters
are varied enough that you can swap
between them or specialize in one class
as you please
given that it costs you nothing but your
time it's worth having a go at a match
or for even if like me your main tactic
is to roll the pyro and go home with
your flamethrower until the dudes you're
fighting fall down much like valve
Blizzard really swings and misses and
half Stern is another solid example the
turn-based collectible card game is
accessible with a free battlenet account
sure you can drop money on the extra
campaigns or booster packs but you can
also buy everything the game has on
offer with in-game gold if you spend
enough time racking up wins the wildly
addictive card game is also playable on
iOS and Android so there's really no
getting away from it whether you're into
them or not there's just no denying the
dominance of MOBAs or the popularity of
dota 2 valve appears for the second time
on this list for a damn good reason here
while riots League of Legends certainly
also deserves a mention dr. twos
deplored demand of skill and complex
gameplay mechanics are a little
mind-blowing the fact that dota 2 has
strategic and combat techniques so
refined that the game is the feature of
an annual eSports tournament with an 18
million dollar prize pool really does
speak for itself in the realm of great
free-to-play MMO sit was really tricky
for me to choose between the Lord of the
Rings Online and Star Wars The Old
Republic but ultimately the sci-fi
universe won out of course you used to
have to pay for the ultra public but now
that much of the game is free not
suffering from server issues and loaded
with new content it's really worth your
time and buy your time I mean
thousands of hours of your existence
because this is an MMO we're talking
about Star Wars The Old Republic has so
much going on from expansive quests to
engaging character building mechanics
you can see why they tried to charge for
it the heart of this game is powered by
fans love for the Star Wars universe and
getting to be a part of it has not
stopped being cool even decades of Star
Wars games later Alien Swarm is not as
high-profile as a lot of the other games
on this list but given that it has a 10
out of 10 on Steam after more than
11,000 reviews that's a good argument
for why it should be while a lot of
free-to-play games are really only free
up to a point
Alien Swarm is really totally completely
downloaded and go nuts free perhaps the
only other free shooter good enough to
compete with tf2 although coincidentally
also made by well Alien Swarm
is a damn to light team up with three
pals to beat the goo out of some alien
beasties as any of four classes and
eight characters there are constantly
new things to unlock and you can even
make your own maps in the game editor if
you like Alien Swarm
is perfect for the free to play haters
as there's not a micro transaction in
sight and finally topping off my list
for its breadth of content and the fact
that they could easily have charged 40
bucks for the same game it's part of
Exile as a massive Diablo 2 fan path of
Exile was a game I picked up with a
heavy dose of skepticism planning to try
it out for 15 minutes to see what all
the fuss was about it's multiple levels
and an entire evening later I remember
that it's bloody hard to put down a
fantastic RPG with its enormous skill
tree smooth a RPG mechanics and
extensive item combination options this
is the kind of free-to-play game that
you actually feel guilty about not
paying for the customization options are
so expensive that you're actually able
to create the precise special snowflake
hero that you have in your head if
you're a fan of a RPGs you'd be crazy
not to give path of exile 15 minutes oh
you know
entire evening let me know down in that
comment box which free-to-play game is
your favorite or you can let me know on
my Twitter where I'm at Jess McDonald
I'll see you again next week